la batalla para la presidencia francesa
empezó fuertemente este domingo eric se
mudó el candidato polemista de
ultraderecha inició su primer mitin
frente a unas 13.000 personas según los
organizadores
revelando en el proceso el nombre de su
partido reconquista
exigimos el reto es inmenso si gano
estas elecciones no será una alternancia
más sino la reconquista del país más
bello del mundo
en su discurso
llamó a los electores de ma jin lo pen
del partido de extrema derecha
agrupación nacional a unirse a su
campaña tal como los del partido o los
republicanos que eligieron su
representante este sábado la liberal
valleys y piques en otra zona de la
región parisina el candidato izquierda
radical son lic menos un reunió menos
gente que su opositor directo 4500 según
el propio partido los insumisos el líder
insumiso no perdió oportunidad para
atacar a su nuevo enemigo político el ex
de move
conocíamos en el pasado los enemigos del
pueblo ahora descubrimos a los enemigos
de la raza humana es el señor se murió
ambos candidatos hicieron promesas para
reducir impuestos y darles subsidios a
los más necesitados por ahora y según
los recientes sondeos los dos candidatos
siguen en tercera y cuarta posición para
las presidenciales de 2010 y dos detrás
del actual presidente emmanuel mccomb
imagine lópez la líder del partido
agrupación nacional su rival en la
segunda vuelta
comicios